gord vent left Fort James by ship with  the redheaded woman where did they go we  are the black wolf company we are your  outlaws you are prostitutes for fur this  is our land and you [ __ ] don't belong  here those who carry on their business  are not our competition  they are our sworn enemies the only  thing the company's had on us until now  is structure and organization and that's  right ha then us what's up one oh we go  north to the ice cost of your life I'm  already dead this is my resurrection and  we're about to sell right to the dentist  palm  you who remain loyal to the Hudson's Bay  Company  the HPC flag will no longer fly above  Fort James your loyalty will result in  Milton but death starvation poverty my  mother's people have fought like this  for centuries I can't sit around here  like a goddamn coward and let an  innocent woman died I know I can stop it  we won't stretch them out we will drain  every last one of them  Oh stain from you  he took everything  you